if you're curious about my to-do lists
my weekly schedule and my monthly goals
i'm going to share them with you today
on this video
hi i'm evan carmichael i believe in
entrepreneurs and i recently got a great
question for one of my newsletter
subscribers
love you guys dion who's asking about my
schedule and routine
dion wrote in to say hi evan thank you
for your recent emails and for your
inspirational videos which i have now
started to implement into my daily
routine awesome this brings me to a
question relating to routine and how you
organize your day
we'd love to know what your to-do list
looks like your weekly schedule your
monthly goals and beyond
i think it would help a lot of people
like myself plan their day and achieve
their goals in a workable format if you
were to share how you plan
hope that makes sense dion so this is a
great question let's start with the
to-do lists
so with my to-do list i use two systems
tools
one is my email and one is evernote
email i'll use
for email obviously when somebody emails
me something
and i need to review it i'll usually
give it a star i use gmail you can start
and then i'll come back to it on monday
will be my time i have a chunk of time
set to be able to manage those tasks i
don't have a set time of the day where i
do
email from my general inbox and so i'm
doing email typically from my tablet
when i'm waiting in line or i'm outside
or whatever when i have down time and
traveling
that's when i'll check my email and it's
not always conducive to reviewing
documents and doing kind of the bigger
projects
and so i set aside a specific time for
that and i'll just start
when i know i have to come back to it
i'll also use email for the videos
so in my morning schedule i'm checking
my youtube channel looking the comments
that you guys have
and if i promise somebody i'm going to
make them a video often i'll say hey
this is a great question i'll make a
video reply for you then i will
send myself an email and copy and paste
that in and then on wednesday which is
video day
i'll look at all those emails and start
making videos to answer those questions
for everything else in terms of to-do
lists i use evernote
and that's where it's not reactionary
right the other ones were reactionary
where i'm getting an email or i'm
getting a comment
here is more purposeful planning where
i'm making a list of things that i need
to do
and i love evernote for that it's easy
to update and i have access to it
on my phone tablet computer laptop
everything
uh and what i'll do is i'll just make
different folders for each of the main
things that i'm working on and so
i have in my weekly schedule set time to
do set projects
and when it's time for that project to
open up i'll go to my evernote folder
and see all the things that i have to do
i usually have a
to-do list at the top in each folder
of the kind of priority things i need to
get done and then
ideas below right if i have an idea for
something
i'll just add it to that evernote file
so i'm not you know staying awake late
at night trying to remember and hope i
don't forget it for the next day
but it may not be a priority like i got
to get working on this right now
so when i'm starting up whatever task
i'll load the evernote file see what's
most important
and if i finish it then i can start
working on the other ideas that i came
up with
the next question was about my weekly
schedule so my mornings usually start
the same way i will wake up i'll have my
lentils i will
write down three things i'm grateful for
i will check my youtube comments and my
social media comments
i will also check my email folder from
my vips
which will be my family my staff
and the people in my movement coaching
program
and get back to those people pretty
quickly
then everything else is different
depending on the day
and i'm a huge believer in chunking
similar tasks together and not being
bombarded
uh and being super reactionary i believe
in really trying to be proactive in
scheduling your week to get
what you want to get done done so monday
is my get stuff done for the weekday
and that's usually starts with
me look at all of the things that i
start during the week right all those
emails that i put a star
attached to i'll look through those and
get those done so reviewing documents
getting back to emails
i will plan out the facebook campaigns
and the twitter campaigns for the week
my team will put together pictures and
things for me to approve i don't
actually design anything but it's more
you know anything going out has my name
on it so i want to make sure that it's
been approved and i like it
so i'll look at all the stuff that
they've sent me and just
it's it's admin day you know let's get
all the stuff done
for the week day and so i've divided my
day into
three chunks the first chunk is just
doing that stuff
the second chunk is thinking about my
authors i have a website where authors
can contribute content and so
i'll spend in each chunk an hour and a
half and that second chunk i'm worried
about my website
and seo stuff and author feature
requests
and any issues that i need to deal with
around that looking at the new backend
that we're working on and so on
and then the last chunk on that monday
is going to be
about my zuga guides and expanding them
and adding more to them and promoting
them and anything related to
the zuga guides happens at that time so
why it's great is because
you know people my team might email me
and say hey here's something new for the
author back-end or here's something new
for the zooka guys that i want you to
check out and if i just
responded to it right then quickly right
away it's great i guess for my team that
they have a fast answer
but it kills my time and productivity
because now i'm just being reactionary
to what they're sending me
so instead i save it you know to the
folder and know that hey on
on monday i have time for this i'm going
to look look at it
and i'm going to get back to you and so
that frees up the rest of my week to do
other things
tuesday is my writing and researching
day so i'm writing the book that could
be where i'm spending my time
researching writing for the book
now i'm spending a lot of time on my
youtube videos and researching the
famous entrepreneurs and finding clips
and now that i have a system for that
i'm going to try to involve my team
more into it because it's super taxing
it takes me the whole day tuesday
to uh find all that information to make
the videos and i'm hoping that that can
be now delegated and i can go back to
writing my book
so anything related to research or
writing or
if i'm asked to write something for an
for an article or
a guest post somewhere that'll all fall
under my tuesday category and i
book off the whole day to be able to
free up my time to do that wednesday's
video day so
today is wednesday i don't know when the
video is going live but today actually
is wednesday
and uh i you know have the mindset now
where hey i gotta be
i gotta be enthusiastic i gotta be
exciting you know monday tuesday might
be the
i don't need to talk to anybody i can
just sit there and work and now
wednesday is more extrovert itself
and uh answering your questions and i'll
make 13 videos
uh a week typically and record them and
send them off to my
editor christina to put together for you
thursday is my public facing day that's
when all the meetings happen so meetings
phone calls google plus hangouts
uh media uh corporate initiatives things
that i'm working on where i need to talk
to you
somebody else that's outside my company
that's not an email happens on thursdays
so
i try to line up back-to-back meetings
if i'm meeting somebody
it's usually at a local whole foods cafe
and then i line up back-to-back
calls and hangouts i find with the
meetings i give people a two hour window
on a thursday so i don't know exactly
what it is i want to say it's thursday
from like 11 to 1
would be meetings face to face and then
i give them the time slot and they can
either book for this week or next week
or the week after and
usually because my schedule fills up
they're looking at three or four weeks
out but it saves so much time of having
to go back and forth and back and forth
this time this time this time work and
then the afternoon is gonna be all phone
calls and and hangouts
and or skype calls or whatever um those
are all again back to back to back to
back to back there's a little bit of
travel time obviously to get from whole
foods to back here
um but again it works and and i enjoy it
and
it's my public facing day it's the day i
have my radio show and basically
anything where i am
out talking to people is for the most
part on that thursday
and then friday there's nothing
scheduled friday is maybe my travel
day if i'm going to an event friday
could be a project day friday
uh jason might come over and we'll work
on something together friday is
super buffer day and i find people
often pack so much in that they have
zero buffer time
and you get stressed out and you go
don't get your stuff done
and so i find that by packing everything
at the start monday is intense right
mondays everything for the week
done if i only had to work monday i
could get everything i needed for the
week done
to run my business and then that gives
me the time to actually go and do
other projects that i'm excited about so
i find having that buffer at the end
super helpful and sometimes i use it and
sometimes i don't
and just depends on what's happening in
my life and my business and then in
terms of monthly goals i
check a number of stats religiously
every month when midnight hits on the
first of every month
i have an excel file full of all these
things that i track
uh things like on my youtube channel how
many views how many subscribers
i'll check how many people on my
newsletter list i'll check how many
sales we made i'll check how many
uh web visitors we had to our website
and
some of the data is immediately
actionable and others i just keep just
just to track and know the biggest goal
i'm working on right now
is i want to be the number one youtuber
at the agency
that i'm at so i'm represented by a
talent agency and
they represent experts who are off you
know delivering their expertise and all
sorts of different formats
and i want to be the number one youtuber
at the agency it's a goal i set
uh when i first joined about a year and
a half ago and i am the number two
youtuber
and i'm like this close this close i've
had months where i've passed and then go
down and pass
so the challenge is you know i'm growing
i love you guys for all the
for all the love and the comments and
the traction and the sharing
but the number one person is growing too
so it's not it's a moving target
so i want to be consistently number one
and that's my biggest
goal at the moment i find having that
competition
that's a friendly competition you know
i'm friendly with the other person
but i find having that competition kind
of helps drive me a little bit more
so those are my to-do lists my weekly
schedule
the things that i look at monthly and my
goals i'd love to know
i'd love to know from you guys what the
most important
tool is that you find helpful in your
business
leave in the comments below i want to
see if i'm missing something and there's
a blind spot
that i have your favorite tool that
helps you run your business leave in the
comments below
thank you guys so much for watching if
you liked the video you want to see more
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and the newsletter
continue to believe and i'll see you
soon